[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle 360 voici les titres
12e la cérémonie de commémoration de
l'esclavagé dont les jardins du
luxembourg la dernière pour françois
hollande qui a jugé plus que jamais
nécessaire de faire la paix les des
mémoires invitant emmanuel macron
apporter à son tour ce message reportage
et décryptage dans cette élection les
législatives continue de secouer
l'échiquier politique à gauche le sort
de manuel valls n'en finit pas de faire
des vagues
jean luc mélenchon qui rompt avec les
communistes sera candidat à marseille à
droite à la synthèse c'est fait mais
dans la douleur
analyse à suivre et l'ondé de choc
déclenchée par l'élection d' emmanuel
macron ne s'arrête pas aux murs du
palais bourbon
la secousse pourrait se faire sentir
jusqu'au sénat où un groupe
parlementaire en marche pourrait voir le
jour et entraîner une recomposition
politique inédite le débat dans un
instant et je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez réagir à cette émission sur
twitter le hashtag présidentielle à 360
pour m'accompagner cet après midi
jusqu'à 19h30 thème traduire direct de
la salle des conférences du sénat
le bol des plex a tout de suite
[Musique]
dernier discours officiel de françois
hollande ce matin lors de la cérémonie
de commémoration de l'esclavagé dans les
jardins du luxembourg au sénat un
président soucieux vous allez l'entendre
d'assurer la transmission on écoute le
chef de l'état c'était une copie ou
philosophiques alors que d'émotions
partagées
c'est aussi une transmission
il y avait pour lui sûrement l'émotion
liée à sa première sortie comme
présidente élue au delà de 10 8 mai et
puis il ya la proche de la transmission
effet qui viendra que le 14 e faqih
vedra blanche et qui scellera à ce
moment là sa prise de fonction j'en ai
terminé avec des cérémonies comme
président de la république
mais la politique elle est celle que
tout citoyen quelle a été sa place
qu'était son rôle quelle que soit sa
position doit avoir à l'esprit la
polique c'est l'avis de la france
la police et les choix essentiels pour
le pays et donc nul ne peut se mettre à
l'écart et il ya toujours une utilité
se poser cette même question qui revient
sans cesse comment puis je être utile à
mon pays et bien c'est à cette question
que je vais répondre maintenant
réfléchir en travaillant en produisant
et en intervenant cas ça me paraît très
inquiet il s'agissait de la 12e journée
nationale des mémoires de la traite de
l'esclavagé et de leurs abolitions
une cérémonie en présence de françois
hollande emmanuel macron sur le thème on
l'a entendu de la transmission quentin
calmer c'est la deuxième fois que les
deux présidents se retrouvent ensemble à
quelques jours de la passation de
pouvoir est à l'occasion de la 12e
cérémonie de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
une cérémonie comme à l'accoutumée
organisée dans les jardins du sénat
ces entraînements mais je ne peux pas
corps organique
emmanuel macron plus effacé que lundi
sous l'arc de triomphe
car aujourd'hui il s'agit de la dernière
cérémonie officielle du quinquennat de
françois hollande
et pour cet ultime discours le président
a insisté sur sa politique mémorielle
il s'agit pas d'opposer une douleur à
une autre la concurrence des mémoires
est un mensonge
il n'y a pas de reine de hiérarchie dans
l'horreur de la souffrance dans la
barbarie
nous ne sommes pas là pour faire des
comparaisons nous sommes là pour
empêcher que ce qui a été le pire puisse
se reproduire
l'occasion également d'inviter son
successeur à reprendre le flambeau et
nous devons continuer à nous battre
contre les divisions qui déchirent les
peuples y compris ici contre les
discours qui jette les gens les uns
contre les autres
contre les as les intégristes contre les
obscurantismes contre les
communautarismes
il ya encore beaucoup à faire monsieur
le président ainsi en 2018 la fondation
pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé verra le
jour
présidée par jean marc ayrault l'idée
avait été lancée par jacques chirac en
2006 et reprise l'an dernier par
françois hollande
avec cette dernière image d'un président
sur le départ
seul au moment de repartir du sénat
quand son successeur se lance dans un
long bain de foule
son premier depuis l'élection et avant
de se rendre à cette cérémonie françois
hollande a présidé son dernier conseil
des ministres faisant l'éloge du
dialogue social dans un message
implicite à emmanuel macron julien des
pages
les mines sont graves et les sourires
timides autour de la table 17 ministres
et 20 secrétaires d'état tous les
membres du gouvernement sans exception
sont présents
dernière prise de parole sous les
dorures du salon murat à l'issue de ce
conseil des ministres françois hollande
est applaudi par tout son gouvernement
c'est un moment à la fois solennel un
moment grave et en même temps un moment
team fin triste parce qu'on sait que
d'une certaine façon le travail accompli
en en est fier sur le perron de l'elysée
françois hollande prend le temps de
saluer un à chacun de ses collaborateurs
tous ont conscience qu'une page se
tourne certains ont même voulu garder un
dernier souvenir c'est le crayon que le
président de la république sur sa table
c'était le ministre très particulier
vous le demandez si je pouvais je
prendrais
les conserves de passer le bac ça lui
plaisait mais pour son 250e et ultime
conseil des ministres le président de la
république a tenu à adresser un dernier
message très politique
l'acte qui a été posé dans ce
quinquennat de m le dialogue social au
coeur de la transformation de l'économie
c'est un point très important sur lequel
il a beaucoup c'est vrai insisté
et il a dit que chaque fois qu'on avait
pu quelquefois l'oublier ça pouvait
coûter cher une mise en garde destinée à
son successeur emmanuel macron qui veut
aller vite et gouverner par ordonnances
mercredi prochain c'est lui qui
présidera ce conseil des ministres avec
sa nouvelle équipe
quel est ce la ti vente a dynamité le ps
mûri mon lendemain de la présidentielle
le parti socialiste est une nouvelle
crise dont le point d'orgue semble avoir
été atteint avec la question de
l'investiture de manuel valls tandis que
benoît hamon entend lancer de son côté
un mouvement politique trans partisan
aux rêves états les ténors socialistes
n'ont qu'une idée sauver la gauche mais
chacun sa technique benoît hamon en
temps la reconstruire après les
législatives avec un mouvement politique
c'est un mouvement qui est un mouvement
trans partisan le 1er juillet que je
lancerai qui se nourrira du travail des
intellectuels de cette innovation
citoyenne et démocratique que nous avons
mis en oeuvre pendant la campagne
présidentielle je pense qu'il faut que
la gauche se régénère qu'il y ait des
lieux dans lesquels elle travaille elle
vivent au delà des partis politiques
au-delà des partis oui mais en restant
tout de même au ps avec une promesse il
s'opposera à la majorité présidentielle
dans la foulée anne hidalgo christiane
taubira et 200 signataires lancent un
autre satellite nommé dès demain un
mouvement d'innovation pour une
démocratie européenne écologique et
sociale pas très éloigné donc de l'idée
de benoît hamon
d'ailleurs
des amis à lui ou signé l'appel avec
anne hidalgo et donc moi je ne vois rien
aujourd'hui qui doit être contradictoire
dans tous ceux qui veulent reconstruire
une espérance certains tentent de se
détacher de l'appareil d'autres optent
pour la synthèse
il imagine un ps dit d'autonomie
constructive distincts donc de la
majorité présidentielle mais pas non
plus dans l'opposition
et puis il ya ceux qui parient gros
comme manuel valls qui choisit la
majorité présidentielle une prise de
risque peu concluante à ce jour il n'est
pas dans les critères d'acceptation de
sa demande d'investiture et nous n'avons
pas vocation à recycler pour prendre un
terme classique nous avons vocation à
faire à construire une nouvelle offre
politique citoyenne pire il est
actuellement sous le coup d'une
procédure d'exclusion du parti
socialiste de quoi refroidir ceux qui
seraient tentés de le suivre et on va
tout de suite se retrouver à tam tran
huy en direct de la salle des
conférences du sénat pour une première
réaction à cette actualité politique
tam vous êtes aux côtés de didier
guillaume le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat
effectivement on parlait avec didier
guillaume de l'impact de cette
présidentielle notamment sur le sénat
alors didier guillaume faut-il un groupe
de la république en marche au sénat
selon vous tout de suite ou après les
prochaines élections sénatoriales
non mais je ne sais pas ça les collègues
qui sont membres de en marche prendront
la décision pour l'instant le groupe
socialiste et républicain a décidé de
rester ensemble de rester ensemble
jusqu'aux législatives et nous verrons
après la question qui se pose est vous
souhaitez quand même la constitution
d'un groupe ce serait normal pour la
question qui se pose à nous qui se
posent à tous les socialistes et la
question que le parti socialiste aurait
dû soumettre hier et y répondre c'est
sommes nous dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition c'est l'énergie il n'ya pas
une autre question est ce n'est pas
tranché
et moi je souhaite que nous soyons dans
la majorité parce qu emmanuel macron a
été élu face au front national et
beaucoup de français ont voté contre
l'extrême droite
mais il a aussi été élu sur un programme
que moi je partage en grande partie en
immense partie et je souhaite faire
partie de cette majorité présidentielle
et cette majorité parlementaire il ya
énormément de sénateurs qui sont dans ce
cas là mais il faut s'exprimer on veut
pas rester en l'air comme cela et le
pays
ne peut pas attendre plus longtemps le
pays ne peut pas se permettre d'avoir
des atermoiements que emmanuel macron
président que son gouvernement qu'il
nommera ne réussissent pas donc c'est la
question que nous devons nous poser dans
les jours et les semaines qui viennent
de vous souhaitez rejoindre la majorité
présidentielle quitte à ce que bien cela
vous vaio l'exclusion du parti société
c'est pas du tout ça dans n'y a pas
d'exclusion moi j'ai voté pour emmanuel
macron comme tous les socialistes donc
nous sommes dans la majorité
présidentielle
la question c'est la majorité
parlementaire allons nous voter pour les
réformes et pour le programme que va
présenter
emmanuel macron et surtout lorsque le
premier ministre fera sa déclaration de
politique générale
c'est là où les parlementaires devront
s'exprimer est ce qu'il donne le quitus
est ce qu'il doit pour la déclaration de
politique générale ou contre moi
j'appellerai les sénateurs de gauche les
sénateurs socialistes à voter pour
et c'est là où on verra ce qu'il en est
mais moi j'ai j'ai pas de doute
êtes vous favorable à l'idée d'un report
des élections sénatoriales
on parle d'un possible report d'un an
car il ya dans le programme d' emmanuel
macron une grande réforme du parlement
avec notamment la diminution du nombre
de parlementaires
c'est à dire que oui là la question
c'est celle là si nous voulons diminuer
le nombre de parlementaires de députés
et de sénateurs et que ça se voit dans
le quinquennat
alors il n'y a pas d'autre solution que
de voter un texte très rapidement pour
dire qu aux prochaines législatives de
2022 ira - une parlementaire parce que
ça ne peut pas se faire pour les
législatives dans un mois et pour les
sénatoriales n'y a pas d'autre solution
que de reporter les sénatoriales de 2007
à 2010 8,7 une solution pauvre oui j'y
suis très favorable j'ai d'ailleurs un
peu travaillé sur le sujet afin de
préparer ce texte de loi pour un d'une
diminution générale de tous les
sénateurs en 2021 est comme ça ce serait
dans ce quinquennat que le nombre de
parlementaires auraient diminué c'est un
engagement du président mais c'est un
engagement qui avaient tous les
candidats à la présidentielle et moi je
pense qu'il faut le mettre en
application
il racontera l'autre actualité du jour à
manuel valls dont vous êtes très proche
fait l'objet d'une procédure qui peut
aboutir à une éventuelle exclusion du
parti socialiste est ce que vous le
comprenez non mais non seulement je le
comprends pas mais ça n'existera pas ou
alors il faudrait exclure les 1500
les socialistes qui ont parrainé manuel
marquant alors il ne sera pas assez à
près de deux responsables du parti
socialiste pourrait pour les exclure
parce qu'ils sont tous exclus non tout
ça c'est n'importe quoi qui voulaient
d'investiture il a dit une chose manuel
valls comme tous les responsables
politiques c'est que le parti du
socialisme d'épinés aujourd'hui il est
mort celui d'aujourd'hui
mais les idées socialistes restent la
gauche et la droite reste il faudra
construire quelque chose d'autre mais
pour l'instant ce parti là où
aujourd'hui on voit que des leaders de
notre parti politique créé les tribunes
créer des mouvements on leur dit rien
il ya eu des frondeurs prenant ces
photos dire à martine aubry
on ne dit rien éluder frondeurs pendant
cinq ans qu'ils ont déposée nous
soutient de ceinture on leur dit rien et
pour voudrait exclure quelqu'un qui a
pris position pour un candidat qui a
fait barrage au front national et qui
est président de la république ça n'a
aucun sens il ne sera peut-être pas
déféré en commission des conflits et
s'il l'était ce serait un drame déferré
un ancien premier ministre
c'est absolument absurde aujourd'hui la
question qui se pose est que nous avons
évoquée au début de notre entretien
c est ce que des socialistes sont pour
soutenir ce gouvernement a dit qu'il
était dans l'opposition
et bien voilà les autres socialistes
nous avons des divergences c'est la
question qui vous est posée si les
socialistes répondent oui benoît hamon
devra en tirer les conséquences si les
socialistes répondent non nous sommes
dans l'opposition c'est à nous d'en
tirer les conséquences
mais aujourd'hui s'agit pas d'exclure
s'agit de rassembler pour la france pour
les françaises et des français
merci beaucoup d'idées guillaume
d'apparaître sur la question merci
beaucoup un thème pour cette réaction
jean luc mélenchon lui le candidat
malheureux de la france a soumise à la
présidentielle assure qu'il compte se
présenter aux législatives à marseille
dans la 4e circonscription des bouches
du rhône il l'a dit dans une lettre
envoyée aux militants alors que la
rupture semble consommée avec le parti
communiste français nelson j'étais entre
la france insoumise et le parti
communiste
le dialogue est rompu depuis hier pas
d'accord national et donc pas de
candidature commune aux législatives
mais le mouvement de jean luc mélenchon
qui a obtenu près de 20% des voix au
premier tour de la présidentielle
apparaît en position de force
moi je fais la différence entre une
direction du parti communiste qui a
l'air un petit peu enfermé dans je ne
sais trop quoi c'est difficile de
comprendre ses motivations et des
dizaines et des centaines et des
milliers de militants communistes qui
ont participé à la campagne
présidentielle et qui ont envie de
construire dans le cadre de la france
ont soumis un rassemblement pour ces
élections législatives
en tout cas à nous la maison est
toujours ouverte pour tout le monde et
jusqu'à date limite de dépôt des
candidats au mahb même après pour ceux
qui voudront venir aider les dirigeants
de la france insoumise affirme même
avoir déjà investi une vingtaine de
candidats communistes
la direction du pcf de son côté rejette
la faute sur les équipes de jean luc
mélenchon et envisage toujours de
trouver un accord au niveau local jean
luc mélenchon et ses principaux
conseillers ont décidé hier soir seuls
de rompre les discussions on ne peut
aujourd'hui que le regretter mais ce
n'est pas pour ça que nous on simule un
fan de la partie du rassemblement
on continuera le construire à l'échelle
de son territoire quant à jean luc
mélenchon il retournera faire des
meetings sur la canebière puisqu'il sera
probablement candidat aux législatives à
marseille et autres réactions politiques
celle du sénateur écologiste andré
gattolin il répondait aux questions de
tam traînions l'écoutent
oui andré gattolin qu'elle va être pour
vous l'impact de cette élection
présidentielle survient la future
configuration du sénat faut-il un futur
groupe de la république en marche pour
vous qui avez voté dès le premier tour
pour emmanuel macron moi je pense
sincèrement que il faut tenir compte de
cette évolution
je pense pas que ça puisse se faire par
un groupe puisque les gens ont été élu
sous une étiquette et un respect des
électeurs mais qui ait une coordination
qui ne sortent d'un terreau groupes qui
se produisent jusqu'au prochain
renouvellement on sait pas là le bruit
court actuellement qui aurait peut-être
une prolongation
d'ailleurs d'un an du mandat des
sénateurs
dans tous les cas je pense qu'il ya bien
sûr une nécessité je crois même si on
fait des calculs un peu rapide qui n
majorité de pro macro nist aujourd'hui
au sein du sénat
et ça on en a besoin pour engager des
réformes rapidement mais avec des gens
qui viennent d'horizons politiques très
différents il est peut-être plus
important qui ait une logique je dirais
d'intergroupe croiser tout en conservant
les groupes s'en remettre les équilibres
en cause complètement avant les
élections puis c'est peut-être une façon
aussi de mieux communiquer avec les
anciens groupes politiques
si je comprends bien un intergroupe
d'ici les prochaines élections
sénatoriales et après les élections
sénatoriales
un groupe de la république en marche ça
serait la meilleure logique à mon sens
et qu'est ce que vous pensez
effectivement vous l'avez abordé de
cette rumeur qui parle d'un possible
report de l'élection sénatoriale d'un an
notamment parce que eh bien le projet d'
emmanuel macron prévoit une grande
réforme du parlement
oui alors après c'est compliqué
d'engager cette réforme avec une chambre
nouvellement élu et sans avoir présenté
le projet sage
ça paraît logique qu'il ya des problèmes
techniques
puisqu'on est à moins de six mois du
semi renouvellement du sénat
donc certains comptes de campagne ont
été ouverts mais ça ça peut pouvoir se
régler et je pense qu'effectivement dans
la mesure où emmanuel macron en l'état
du sénat tel qu'il est configuré
actuelle actuellement pourrait disposer
d'une majorité certes composite mais
d'une majorité
ça permettrait effectivement de mettre
en oeuvre plus rapidement les réformes
qui sont prévues notamment celle sur la
transparence de la vie publique mais
aussi d'autres dossiers qui sont prévues
à très court terme très brièvement lui
faites vous confiance justement pour
régler ces questions environnementales
écologiques un beaucoup disent que son
programme est faible sur ce sujet qu'il
a été floué il ya des choses moi je sais
je connais les gens qui s'occupent de
ces parties du programme
en même temps il ne renie pas les
engagements qui avaient été pris mais
pas tenus par son agent tic
voilà et puis même sur le niveau de
nucléaire et comme il a l'air résolu à
tenir ses engagements
c'est un bon point mais moi l'aspect
premier de ma motivation c'est la
question européenne et enfin on a un
président de la république qui est
volontariste et qui a un vrai discours
européen donc j'ai des gens moins 50%
dans lequel je me sens totalement bien
et on vient pour europe écologie et les
verts
c'est donc merci beaucoup et andré
gattolin d'avoir a répondu à nos
questions
voilà pour cette réaction je sais un peu
plus tôt cet après midi lors de la
synthèse chez les républicains
hier le nouveau projet pour les
législatives a été adopté il se veut le
dow jones et à des programmes de fillon
sarkozy et juppé et mme est au coeur des
propositions une baisse de l'impôt sur
le revenu pour améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat jérôme ramener fini la campagne
présidentielle et avec elle les
républicains veulent tenter ray le
projet de françois fillon aux côtés de
leurs alliés de lui dit
ils ont donc présenté leur nouvelle
copie rédigé en trois jours une synthèse
avec comme maître mot le pouvoir d'achat
la synthèse portera eric woerth le
présentera devant vous dans quelques
instants
autour d'une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat des
français notamment les classes moyennes
qui ont été massacrés au cours de ce
quinquennat de françois hollande et pour
laquelle emmanuel macron dans les
responsabilités qui étaient les siennes
a naturellement sa part de
responsabilité et d'une baisse des
impôts oubliée la hausse de la tva
retour des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées objectifs de réduction du
nombre de fonctionnaires passé de 500
milles à 300000 un mix des projets de
juppé sarkozy et fillon
une synthèse dont la droite n'est pas
familière mais ne leur dites pas que
cela ressemble à la synthèse socialiste
synthèse formateur le projet de monsieur
m'a dit que ça monsieur m'a confié à la
droite et au centre lui dei
malgré des tentations individuel de
rejoindre emmanuel macron est encore
alliés aux républicains et semble bien
plus à l'aise avec ce nouveau projet
dans le projet de françois fillon il y
avait quelques aspects quelques
arbitrages qui étaient les siens qui
sent vite manqué l'équipe et moi ce
projet il doit avoir plus d'ambition que
celui de monsieur mapon et plus d'équité
l'essai de cas que celui qui a été
portée par françois fillon les 577
candidats de la droite et du centre
législatifs seront donc bien sous une
seule et même bannière
intitulé majorité pour la france avec
l'espoir de l'emporter ou à minima de
limiter la casse dans les rangs et après
les législatives les élections
sénatoriales elles doivent se tenir le
dimanche 24 septembre et pourrait elle
aussi bouleversé le paysage de la haute
assemblée un groupe parlementaire en
marche prête ainsi voir le jour et
modifier la composition des groupes aux
sellin cc sexo créer un groupe en marche
au sénat françois patriat a testé l'idée
auprès des sénateurs mais visiblement
pour le moment peu sont prêts à quitter
leur chapelle changement de formule donc
il propose de créer après les
sénatoriales en septembre une majorité
présidentielle formée par des sénateurs
de tous les groupes qui s'engage à
soutenir le projet d' emmanuel macron et
ne peut pas y avoir de soutien à la
carte doit y avoir un soutien non pas un
soutien godillots le soutien massif à
l'action du président république s nous
allons avoir un grand président
république il faut l'aider un modèle
auquel adhèrent déjà bon nombre de
socialistes
comme jean pierre sueur je me sentirais
très bien dans une majorité vivante
qu'on pauvre composé de plusieurs
groupes différents
mais bien sûr unis par une solidarité et
c'est peut-être ce qui a manqué à
françois hollande
voyez-vous les frondeurs et les autres
étaient dans le même groupe mais il n'y
a pas de cohérence pour les écologistes
divisés sur leur soutien à emmanuel
macron on imagine mal la faisabilité
d'une telle majorité
il ya des problèmes non seulement
technique mais politique parce que sur
quelle base des gens qui étaient sur des
projets différents encore des votes
assez dur ici ou ont refusé le budget
ont refusé les choses ils vont voter la
même chose donc c'est effectivement
assez intéressant chez les radicaux de
gauche où la majorité des sénateurs
soutient le nouveau président certains
proposent que le groupe puisse
accueillir les soutient emmanuel ma cour
et ouvre le débat danse présidentielle
360 avec mes invités sur ce plateau
eliane assassi bonsoir vous êtes
présidente du groupe communiste ici au
sénat sénatrice de seine saint denis
merci d'être avec nous jund longue et
également sur ce plateau bonsoir dire
les républicains de la meuse j'accueille
également alain richard bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur socialiste du val d'oise
et jacques mézard vous êtes le président
du groupe rdse ici au sénat ce sénateur
du cantal vous avez soutenu emmanuel
macron dans cette campagne
présidentielle justement première
question pour vous puisque on viens de
l'entendre ce que vous souhaitez et bien
qu'il y ait un groupe parlementaire en
marche
ici au sénat qui pourrait rassembler à
la fois les sénateurs rdse certains
sénateurs socialistes des sénateurs et
l'air est aussi écologistes finalement
vous voulez que nous réunissions tout le
cmfi et descente historique et des
centristes
l'élection du président de la république
ait lieu dimanche
nous sommes mercredi je crois qu'avant
de chambouler tout il est nécessaire
d'avoir des concertations sur le fond
pour savoir que faire avec qui s'il est
nécessaire de faire quelque chose on ne
prend pas des décisions de cette nature
comme ça dans la rapidité
parce que tel ou tel ce serait
autoproclamé leader des macros nist à
supposer que cela existe donc en ce qui
concerne le rds eux nous tenons à ce
groupe et s'il doit évoluer
ça ne se fera pas comme ça à la va-vite
dans n'importe quelle condition il y
aura des candidats aux morsures
sénatoriales ne sommes pas encore oui
vous en doutez alors effarant on a
entendu françois patriat dira et bien il
faut et d'emmanuel macro est ce que ça
suppose justement bien ce soutien de
certains sénateurs sociale et c'est la
constitution d'un groupe qu'ils
soutiendraient la future majorité
présidentielle ma position est personnel
c'est plutôt oui on est dans un régime
parlementaire au sénat
le fait majoritaire s'impose moins
directement
qu'à l'assemblée nationale mais enfin si
on veut qu'un programme sa complice y
ont vu qu'une politique cohérent soient
menées plutôt si bien que elle trouve
des soutiens organisées dans les deux
dans les deux assemblées et donc je suis
convaincu que la géographie des groupes
changera et dans ma vision de l'équipe
des institutions et de la gouvernabilité
du pays comme un détail dont on peut se
préoccuper de temps en temps il est
préférable que les groupes politiques
correspondent à une cohérence et une
harmonie avec la politique que 3
personnes vous seriez prêt à quitter un
groupe socialiste au sénat
si c'était le cas j'espère que vous
serez nombreux à le faire
comment voyez vous les choses à droite
gérard longuet s'est finalement après
les élections sénatoriales
la majorité reste ici à droite ce sera
la solution d'opposition dans le pays si
l assemblée nationale emmanuel macron
une majorité face à une droite
sénatoriale
c'est à dire une droite réfléchisse je
réfléchis j'écoutais al arich a je pense
que j'ai quitté l assemblée nationale
pour trouver justement au sénat une
liberté qui me permet de défendre mes
convictions mais sans avoir l'obligation
de m'opposer si je considère que le
texte présenté bon il m'est arrivé de
très souvent de voter des textes d'un
gouvernement de gauche je trouve
vraiment l'année de la torpiller la
méthode de la responsabilité quand on a
un peu d'expérience donc quels sont pour
vous et eliane assassi comment
voyez-vous finalement l'avenir ici du
groupe communiste après l'élection
macron vous savez je n'ai pas à beaucoup
d'inquiétudes sur le devenir
dessinatrice et des sénateurs
communistes de façon très personnelle
comme la sphère la rue charge je pense
que tous les élus de mon groupe
resteront dans mon groupe dès lors
qu'ils seront bien évidemment bien
évidemment réélu et je crois que le fond
de la question ça s'est passé pour moi
une question de forme c'est là une
question de fond qui a calé le projet
politique de emmanuel macron et je dois
dire qu'en la matière il est un peu
encore opaque on nous annonce un certain
nombre de choses comme le recul des
élections sénatoriales
n'en sais rien et c'était donc je pense
que veut non sur le fond donc le projet
et à partir de là où se déterminera vous
savez nous chez les communistes on a
toujours une ligne c'est n'a pas une
politique au sens général mais dans
notre responsabilité de parlementaires
nous avons toujours dit que nous
voterions tout ce qui va dans le bon
sens et que nous rejette aurions tous
ceux qui iraient dans le mauvais sens
donc c'était facile à ses origines avons
fait la démonstration à plusieurs
reprises durant six dernières années
donc ce qui était vrai hier les
aujourd'hui le sera encore demain
jacques mézard puisque eliane assassi
vient d'évoquer cette rumeur 1 qui
agitent la haute assemblée depuis hier
il y aurait peut-être un report des
élections sénatoriales rappellent
qu'elles sont prévus le 24 septembre
prochain pour notamment et bien
appliquées rapidement le non cumul des
mandats et la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires pour les sénateurs jeu là
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il ya une
corrélation une corrélation évidente
entre la question du non cumul et le
report des élections sénatoriales celle
du ministre je dirais bien au contraire
si longue si l'on lit avec précision le
texte qui a été voté dans des conditions
que je ne rappellerai pas mais vous avez
parlé d'une rumeur moi personnellement
je président groupe personne ne m'a
contacté pour me parler sérieusement de
cette éventualité
donc quand la question sera posée nous y
réfléchirons et nous verrons ce que nous
avons à faire là-dessus mais je crois
que ça fait beaucoup de rumeurs et qu'
il est il est dommageable d'ailleurs de
commencer par lancer des rumeurs le
président de la république quand il aura
communiqué le fera je sais ses capacités
d'homme d'état et puis sa capacité
d'autorité donc je ne doute pas que si
c'est son intention il saura le
transmettre au président du sénat au
groupe politique le revers du sénat
face à cette proposition emmanuel macron
vous pensez les groupes
le président du sénat les groupes
politiques réfléchiront quand la
question sera posée par les véritables
responsables et non par les propagateurs
de rumeurs à la richard c'est vrai que
ça fait partie de son programme cette
réforme institutionnelle on sait qu'il
veut aller vite notamment sur cette
question assez emblématique la réduction
du nombre de parlementaires
alors est ce que vous vous seriez prêt à
le soutenir dans cette démarche qui doit
reporter à les sénatoriales d'un an les
deux choses sont distincts sur la
réduction du nombre
ce n'était pas ma position jusqu'à ces
dernières années et honnêtement je suis
venu dire qu avec l'exigence croissante
d'assiduité de participation de
discussions approfondies des textes puis
aussi il faut bien dire jacques mézard
le dire à 10 fois mieux que moi c'est
assez fréquentes malfaçon législative
qui sont liées à une méthode de travail
qui est améliorée je crois qu'il
vaudrait mieux que nous soyons moins
nombreux et nos amis députés est tout
autant donc ça moi maintenant
tardivement
je suis venu à soutenir cette idée je
crois que il m'a lu ma croix mentionné
l'idée d'un tiers c'est à dire en gros
il assemble extrait un peu en dessous de
400 ce qui veut dire un sénat qui
seraient entre 220 230 quelque chose
comme ça je défends cette idée là leur
ensuite la question du calendrier un peu
secondaire mais c'est à des conséquences
de l'histoire du quinquennat dire que
vous avez lancé une réforme vous voulez
qu'elle s'applique
et donc c'est vrai que ça peut paraître
un peu et un peu contradictoire que
trois mois après on élise une assemblée
dans son ancienne effectifs alors que la
loi est en train d'être détruit discuter
opposition éventuel report des élections
sénatoriales la rattacher une politique
d'ensemble une vision d'ensemble du rôle
du parlement du rôle du poids de chacune
des deux assemblées est en effet de
façon dont le sénat de travail et je
crois que la réduction du nombre peut
poser sur les territoires des problèmes
de lien avec les électeurs c'est nos
grands électeurs mais inversement on
peut donner à chaque sénateur le
sentiment de sa profonde utilité ça veut
dire l'accès à des rapports l'acsa des
responsabilités un suivi plus plus
constant de tel ou tel sujet ça suppose
d'être un petit peu moins nombreux mais
d'être chacun de se sentir indispensable
à sa famille et à sa com et à sa famille
politique à sa commission
eliane assassi votre réaction justement
sur cet éventuel report est ce que ça
sera un mauvais signal envoyé aux
sénateurs je ne prendrai pas parce ce
bout là moi la seule question qui
m'intéresse c'est à quoi sert le
parlement
oui ça c'est une question de foi à
laquelle il convient de répondre et je
ne pense pas qu une des réponses soit la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
comme le disait monsieur longuet
ça pose quand même cette réduction une
question une question démocratique c'est
à dire que nous avons eu ce débat au
moment du projet de loi sur les régions
sur la création des nouvelles régions
nous avons été plusieurs dans plusieurs
groupes ou au sénat affaire à intervenir
pour faire remarquer cette rupture de
proximité des élus avec les populations
et donc si nous réduisions le nombre de
parlementaires pour répondre à une
soi-disante demande populaire ce que
c'est de ça dont il s'agit
je pense qu on se tromperait où on
aurait moins bonne représentativité des
territoires et particulièrement des
territoires ruraux au sein du parlement
donc ça pose beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de questions et la première pour moi et
la question démocratique
oui je crois que là-dessus il faut être
moi je ne suis pas a priori contre la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
mais c'est une course à l'échalote
quand on voit les programmes des
candidats à la présidentielle pas être
désagréable avec ceux qui ont soutenu
françois fillon mais il y en avait
encore plus il y en avait encore plus
alors ça fait plaisir un de cogner sur
la représentation parlementaire
c'est dans l'air du temps le parlement
n'a pas toujours été exemplaire
il faut le dire mais de là
à lutter systématiquement contre le
principe même de la représentation
parlementaire
c'est un autre débat et son temps c'est
le message qui est envoyé par les
français justement les français la
réforme institutionnelle à s'agresser
pas leur priorité dans le quotidien leur
priorité c'est l'emploi c'est le chômage
c'est l'économie par rapport à ça et je
partage l'inquiétude d'eliane assassi
nous avons vécu sur la fusion de régions
une dégradation de la représentation des
territoires ruraux
mon département il ya quatre conseillers
régionaux sur 248 je crois c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pratiquement plus écoutés si
vous supprimez systématiquement la
moitié parce que ça reviendra ça dans
les territoires ruraux des
parlementaires ça veut dire que ça
posera quand même un problème il se
représente a souvent assez parlé avec le
patron de ce problème de la
représentation des territoires ruraux
jacques mézard vous questionnez bien sûr
puisque quelle est sa position je lui en
ai parlé souvent et je dois dire que il
en a il en a jusqu'ici tenu compte
il en a tenu compte et il est conscient
de cela et il en est d'autant plus
conscient que l'entente voix les votes
ce sentiment d'abandon de nombre de
territoires ruraux
il faut pas l'accentuer longtemps je
suis pas contre les évolutions il faut
qu'ils les évolutions mais il faut
qu'elle soit réfléchie alain richard je
reviendrai à ma première question
finalement sur la recomposition
politique induite par cette élection d'
emmanuel macron à ce contrat comme
toujours un groupe socialiste et sur
senna je fais parler que oui mais en
effet c'est ouvert à beaucoup
d'incertitudes et ont chassé une
conversation à laquelle j'attache de
l'importance que j'ai avec emmanuel
macron qui commençait son projet
politique qui essayait de me convaincre
il m'a dit au fond les deux grands
partis majoritaires ne sont plus en
capacité aujourd'hui de formuler une
politique notamment parlé de politique
économique cohérente et d'entraîner
toutes leurs troupes pour mener cette
politique
ça m'a pas fait plaisir quand imad is
able se remettaient en cause
fidélité à une adhésion au parti depuis
longtemps mes derniers mois au film
convaincre c'était une observation exact
qu'il est encore un groupe s'est d'abord
je souhaite qu'il y ait une diversité
politique parce que je ne veux pas que
l'opposition de demain au président
macron se borne à être celle de la
france insoumise et du front national
nous à droite on n'a pas d'attitude a
priori négatif sur beaucoup de
propositions du président macron en
particulier sur la libéralisation de
l'économie
mais nous avons nous sentons le devoir
d' occuper je dirais deux dates de
répondre à une opinion qui a voté pour
nous qui nous a soutenu qu est
minoritaire certes mais qui existent si
nous donnions le sentiment de nous fut
de fusionner ça veut dire que demain il
y aurait la france de macron et deux
extrêmes c'est pas souhaitable pour le
pays on a vu en autriche et l'opposition
emmanuel macron alors c'est le groupe
l'est républicain
ya pas deux y'a pas d'opposition à
première vue d'abord au président de la
république qui n'est pas responsable
devant le parlement
l'opposition c'est celle qui se dressent
contre un gouvernement et son premier
ministre que son responsable devant le
parlement
donc on attend le premier ministre on
attend gouvernement en attend sa
politique président il est élu c'est un
fait il en a pour 5 ans il est
indéboulonnable et donc il faut faire
avec on l'entend mieux on l'est - tant
pis il faut faire avec
en revanche le gouvernement ça c'est la
sphère du parlement est en effet
vis-à-vis de ce gouvernement
je crois qu'il faut des formations
politiques et des choses à dire et qu'il
puisse parler librement sans avoir la
terreur j'ai vécu en montant de
mécontenter le président ou l'affaiblir
est-ce qu'il peut aussi avoir un risque
un peu d'hémorragie
sur mort et au sénat sûrement des
transfuges je n'imagine pas qu'il n'y en
ait pas mais ce sera je crois ce sera
marginal parce que nous sénateurs on a
un calendrier qui n'est pas tributaire
de lection présidentielle à la nasa si
ça c'est pour le cas où emmanuel macron
une majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale s'il ya un gouvernement de
cohabitation comment voyez vous votre
rôle dans ce cas là c'est aussi à
écouter moi je crois que j'ai été clair
y compris avant l'élection d' emmanuel
macron je crois que je les dis ici nous
serons dans une opposition à emmanuel
macron puisque nous avons combattu
c'est un projet politique pour peu qu'on
pour ce qu'on en connaît bien évidemment
mais je le répète encore une fois nous
vote auront tous qu'il ira dans le bon
sens et nous rejetterons tout ce qui ne
va pas dans le bon sens moi je crois
l'expression la présence est
l'expression d'une opposition sont pour
moi aussi l'expression d'une de la
démocratie je suis une fervente
partisane de la proportionnelle et on
m'a toujours rétorquer proportionnelle
attention cela risquerait de faire
rentrer et où le front national est
efficace contre l'extrême droite
moi je considère le tour national ça se
combat sur les idées il et voilà et donc
on a on a été nombreux à contribuer il y
a quelques jours à créer les conditions
de battre le front le front national
mais moi je suis pour l'expression
diverses et diversité diversifié de ce
qui peut s'exprimer dans le pays qui
peut s'incarner par des formations
politiques c'est ça la démocratie
il faut que le sénat soit constructif la
situation du pays nécessite et c'est
l'habitude du sénat d'ailleurs de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
sortir des blocages qui sont
malheureusement une dérive que l'on a
connus ces dernières décennies dans ce
pays et de ce côté là je crois qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir une majorité y
compris au sénat sur de grands objectifs
de grands objectifs mais en gardant ce
qui fait l'identité et la force du sénat
c'est-à-dire la la capacité d'avoir des
expressions libres parce que
faire en groupe j'y réfléchis rond mais
si ce groupe
tous les membres du groupe doivent être
le doigt sur la couture du pantalon je
pense que ce n'est pas bon pour le sénat
mais ce n'est pas bon non plus pour le
président de la république est en tout
cas pas pardon traumatisé par les
frondeurs jacques mézard donc il faudra
bien groupe oc parlementaire les
majorités qui se créent pour anders et
l'assemblée nationale le sénat la
capacité là la capacité de la réflexion
et je ne doute pas que lorsque l'intérêt
primordial les intérêts fondamentaux de
la nation sont en jeu le sénat a la
capacité de faire avancer les choses et
d'être constructif là on évoqué comme ça
qui fait preuve le temps du débat ou
6ème république a prévu les frondeurs ça
s'appelle le 40 le carroi j'ai vécu à
l'assemblée nationale avec un premier
ministre utilisait le 49-3 parce que
nous avions une partie de cette majorité
qui était réticente sur la moitié des
sujets que voir les trois cas si vous
voulez après chacun prend ses
responsabilités
le gouvernement utilise de 49,3 et et si
des parlementaires considèrent que c'est
excessif dont on dissout à la parole et
c'est le fondement même du régime
parlementaire
un régime parlementaire repose sur une
majorité choisi par les électeurs
les gens qui sont dans doivent y être
fidèle sur la méthode la croatie sont
pas fidèles dans les rangs vêtements les
élections sur la méthode macron
puisqu'on parlait du 49-3 l éviter
notamment en ayant recours aux
ordonnances on voit que certains
s'inquiètent notamment les partenaires
sociaux de ce dispositif est ce que vous
pensez qu'il va arriver à convaincre
allez vite cet été alors de la session
extraordinaire de juin je suis hyper
minoritaires sur suivez moi j'ai
toujours défendues lors de lens parce
que sinon il faudrait des années de 500
jours on est toujours dû toujours en
train de courir après le temps après il
ya la question de comment comment elles
sont introduites comme on le ce qui se
produit l'habilitation ça veut bien dire
ce que ça veut dire
mais vous savez les partenaires sociaux
ça c'est un sujet de la plus grande
importance et je rappelle que le projet
principal des manuels mâcon sur ce sujet
c'est de changer le cadre de la
négociation collective mais donc on
parle de tout façon de la négociation
collective et du conclusion d'accords
qui représente une majorité de salariés
par la représentation désorganise la
représentativité des organisations
syndicales donc c'est un sujet très
important pour les partenaires sociaux
enfin l'idée quand même pas de faire
disparaître l'année la démocratie
sociale donc nous allons selon toute
vraisemblance voter la loi
d'habilitation
ce sera un débat profond enfin lui on
parlera en même temps de ski aura dans
lordonnance pendant la session de
juillet et dès ce moment là et en fait
des seins dès son entrée en fonctions ça
irait ans dans quelques jours
emmanuel macron va recevoir les
organisations syndicales puis on sait
comment ça se passe c'est le c'est
l'entrée en matière est ensuite il ya
des réunions très approfondie au
ministère du travail qui est fait pour
ça et où ils ont tous eu leur serviette
et donc il y aura en réalité quelque
chose comme 3 mois de débats intensifs
avec les partenaires sociaux avant la
rédaction finale
les ordonnances et on se retrouvera pas
pour ceux qui sont encore là en octobre
ou en novembre pour éventuellement
statué sur une correction de ce qui est
ce qu'il y aura dans les ordonnances
donc après il ya des effets moi je me
rappelle très bien le plat première
gérard sans rappeler aussi puisque de la
même époque là la première expression de
ça ça a été dur de l'ordre ailleurs
chirac
les secrétaires d'état autre oeuvre à
l'emploi à ce moment là après la
réélection de pompidou 67 y avait une
très faible majorité et il y avait c'est
là qu'on a créé l amp a par exemple il
ya eu toute une série d'ordonnancés
économiques et sociales qui ont été
sortis deux mois ou trois mois et
général de gaulle auparavant avait donné
évidemment l'exemple
donc ça n'est pas antidémocratique c'est
une forme de délégation comme il y en a
dans toutes les démocraties c'est pas un
moyen de contourner parlement selon vous
l'êtes mézard sans recours aux
ordonnances
la santé associés sur cette question de
la réforme du dialogue social où les
icônes du travail écoutez je ne peux pas
penser d'ailleurs je veux c est que le
président de la république ne commence
pas par de la concertation et il a su
montrer d'ailleurs sa capacité de
réflexion et de concertation dans ce que
l'on a appelé la loi macro où il a fait
preuve de beaucoup de respect du
parlement
il a beaucoup écouté du sénat oui et non
parce que vis de nous respecter
il a pris le temps d'écouter et de
dialoguer et il fera de même
ensuite il est un moment où il faut
trancher compte tenu de la nécessité de
faire bouger le domaine économique le
domaine de l'emploi
moi je ne suis pas un fan et vous le
savez des ordonnances
je crois à la nécessité d'avoir un
travail parlementaire et de faire
confiance à la représentation aux
parlementaires mais dans les conditions
nous sommes dans la situation où est ce
pays par rapport à la question du
chômage
à la question de l'économie qu'il y ait
sur quelques dossiers lourds sur
lesquels il y a urgence et bien qu'il y
ait des ordonnances - je le voterai et
je proposerai à mes collègues de mon
groupe d'en faire autant ouais c'est
peut-être on arrache un point de vue
différent de mes trois collègues je suis
fermement opposé aux ordonnances
notamment le président de la république
vient d'être élu il a comme grand projet
de réformer le code du du travail
après ce que nous avons connu avec la
loi travail de madame l connerie c'est à
dire qu'ils vont encore aggraver cette
loi travail ce qui va me semble-t-il
mobiliser encore des milliers et des
milliers de gens dans la rue je peux me
féliciter d'entendre dire qu il
laisser une grande place à la
négociation avec les organisations
syndicales qui va rouvrir le dialogue
social etc
et moi je suis désolé à quoi sert le
parlement
si ce n'est pas pour voter la loi de
prénom a été rappelé un d'habilitation
gratuit à la riche alors nous allons
mais nous ne pourrons pas amendée nous
ne pourrons pas rentrer dans dans le
texte note qu'il n'y aura pas de débat
parlementaire ne pourront pas toucher au
texte elle qui sera présenté et c'est ça
qui est inadmissible quand on veut
porter un aussi grand projet semble-t-il
on a au moins le courage que de le faire
débattre par la représentation populaire
que nous sommes de la même façon que
l'est l'assemblée nationale donc je suis
fermement opposé aux arts de nantes est
particulièrement
contrairement à jacques mais là sur des
textes aussi important vous mettez en
garde emmanuel macron justement sur
écoute et mettre en garde bien voilà je
crois qu'il connaît notre position est
voilà donc je l'aï là il la connaît mais
moi je ne dérogerai pas ça sur cette
question de 7
on aura une loi d'habilitation où les
principes seront débattues et
approfondie trois mois de négociations
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales mais aussi avec des groupes
politiques qui ont parfaitement le droit
de l'est dans le cabinet du ministre
dira mais mon vieux tu m'as bien ces
dernières années monsieur longuet non
messieurs et trois mois de négociations
et puis on sait que ça se termine parce
que sinon la guerre d'embuscades
interminable cc c'est pas bon compte
tenu de l'importance du sujet donc il
aura votre soutien sur le fond
attendez on va quand même des bases du
chant toi c'est la procédure oui il ya
quand même le fond c'est qu'il ya la loi
il ya la loi d'habilitation dorian
l'alouette principe ces parlementaires
vous souhaiter qu'elle soit est bien
courte longue vous pouvez un peu comment
vous voyez les choses dans de bonnes
dispositions
si je n'étais pas dans de bonnes
dispositions qui le sont les français
ont fait un choix
ce choix moi je les jeux les faits il y
à de nombreux avec sheikh jacques un
petit problème on a tous venez je crois
pas le monsieur macro ici je confirme
que nous partagions les mêmes pas deux
mais bien sûr il faut je crois que moi
je souhaite que cette présidence soit
une présidence réussie parce que soyons
réalistes des trois quinquennats
successifs ont laissé quand même un peu
un champ de ruines politique ça ne veut
pas dire que tout a été mal dans ce qui
a été fait par les uns et par les autres
pour des raisons différentes que ce soit
sur la forme que ce soit sur le fond
aujourd'hui le pays a besoin d'être
rassemblée et nous avons besoin d'un
travail constructif justement pour fès
pour faire face à ce que les extrêmes en
distiller dans l'opinion publique il ya
besoin de décisions
il ya besoin d'arbitrage sur des
questions de fond et quand je disais que
la priorité c'est l économie c'était
l'emploi je suis convaincu aujourd'hui
encore plus qu'hier qu'il est nécessaire
d'aller dans ce sens et d'avoir une
session parlementaire très constructive
à ce niveau là parce que nos concitoyens
ne nous le pardonnerait pas déjà on voit
quel est l'état de l'opinion publique
pour connaître moi qui ai soutenus à
fond emmanuel macron pas dire qu'il ya
un enthousiasme généralisé
alain tanner dans l'opinion tournée
merci merci merci à vous merci gérard
longuet vous avez peut-être entendu ce
matin françois hollande a prononcé son
dernier discours officiel lors de la
cérémonie de commémoration de
l'esclavagé dans les jardins du
luxembourg au sénat un président vous
allez l'entendre soucieux d'assurer la
transmission on écoute
c'était une communion philosophique
alors que notion partagée
c'est aussi une transmission
il y avait pour lui sûrement l'émotion
liée à sa première sortie comme
présidente élue au delà du 8 mai et puis
il ya la proche de la transmission et
qui viendra que le 14 e faqih vedra
planches et qui scellera à ce moment-là
ça sa prise de fonction je n'ai terminé
avec les cérémonies comme président de
la république
mais la politique elle est celle que
tout citoyen quelle a été sa place
quelques était son rôle
quelle que soit sa position doit avoir à
l'esprit et la polique c'est l'avis de
la france
la police et les choix essentiels pour
le pays et donc nul ne peut se mettre à
l'écart et il ya toujours une utilité
se poser cette même question qui revient
sans cesse comment puis je être utile à
mon pays c'est à cette question que je
vais répondre maintenant en
réfléchissant travaillant en produisant
et en intervenant comme ça me paraît
tranquille
il s'agissait de la 12e journée
nationale des mémoires de la traite de
l'esclavagé et de leurs abolitions
une cérémonie en présence on vient de le
voir de françois hollande mais aussi d'
emmanuel macron sur le thème de la
transmission des mémoires quentin calmer
c'est la deuxième fois que les deux
présidents se retrouvent ensemble à
quelques jours de la passation de
pouvoir est à l'occasion de la 12e
cérémonie de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
une cérémonie comme à l'accoutumée
organisée dans les jardins du sénat
s'entraîner
j'organise
emmanuel macron plus effacé que lundi
sous l'arc de triomphe
[Musique]
car aujourd'hui il s'agit de la dernière
cérémonie officielle du quinquennat de
françois hollande
et pour cet ultime discours le président
a insisté sur sa politique mémorielle
il s'agit pas d'opposer une douleur à
une autre la concurrence des mémoires
est un mensonge
il n'y a pas de réelle de hiérarchie
dans l'horreur de la souffrance dans la
barbarie
nous ne sommes pas là pour faire des
comparaisons nous sommes là pour
empêcher que ce qui a été le pire puisse
se reproduire
l'occasion également d'inviter son
successeur à reprendre le flambeau et
nous devons continuer à nous battre
contre les divisions qui déchirent les
peuples y compris ici contre les
discours qui jette les gens les uns
contre les autres
contre les as les intégristes contre les
obscurantismes contre les
communautarismes
il ya encore beaucoup à faire monsieur
le président ainsi en 2018 la fondation
pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé verra le
jour
présidée par jean marc ayrault l'idée
avait été lancée par jacques chirac en
2006 et reprise l'an dernier par
françois hollande
avec cette dernière image d'un président
sur le départ seul au moment de repartir
du sénat quand son successeur se lance
dans un long bain de foule
son premier depuis l'élection
prenez un que réjean président du comité
national pour la mémoire et l'histoire
de l'esclavagé une autre invitée il
répond aux questions de sa verrière ogec
le face à face s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
bonjour frédéric régent
bonjour vous êtes donc le président du
comité national pour la mémoire et
l'histoire de l'esclavagé
françois hollande a jugé plus que jamais
nécessaire ce matin de faire la paix des
mémoires cette paix des mémoires
ce n'est toujours pas une réalité dans
la france de 2010 est alors on ne
commence à essayer d'y arriver
alors comment faire une bd mémoire tout
simplement en enseignant l'histoire en
la diffusant donc c'est le but un peu du
concours pédagogique la flamme de
l'égalité donc est piloté par le comité
national pour la mémoire et l'histoire
de l'esclavagé
donc ce concours et on est à sa deuxième
édition et c'est quasiment le deuxième
concours national après celui de la
résistance avec 5000 élèves qui ont
participé 180 classe donc il y a cet
aspect là qui est très important la
recherche historique elle aussi se
développe donc le comité organise un
prix de thèse
donc cette année nous avons eu treize
candidatures lie à 7,8 en avion que deux
candidatures par an donc voilà donc sur
le sait le progrès de l'histoire le
progrès de la diffusion historique qui à
mon sens permettra d'aboutir à la paix
des mémoires parce que la mémoire doit
se construire à partir de l'histoire et
pas à partir de fantasmes mais à votre
sens
la france n'a toujours pas fait la paix
avec son passé d'esclavagistes alors je
pense qu'il ya des revendications
actuellement qui s'explique aussi par
des situations sociales et culturelles
actuelles
voilà deux des personnes qui dans la
société estime qu'elles n'ont pas leur
place qui essaye de trouver une raison
historique à 7 places qu'elles n'ont pas
et c'est aussi un problème du présent
lorsque vous voyez ce qui s'est passé en
outre mer en guyane cette année où les
grands mouvements sociaux de 2009
il ya une revendication du présent et un
an
là on se raccroche au passé en outre-mer
certaines fractures actuels de la
société française s'enracine dans ce
passé tout à fait alors françois
hollande a annoncé ce matin lors de son
discours la création de la fondation
pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé elle sera
créée l'année prochaine présidée par
l'actuel ministre des affaires
étrangères jean marc ayrault quelle sera
la mission cette fondation
alors dans un premier temps c'est un
groupe d'intérêt public qui a pour but
de créer cette fondation est justement
le but c'est de pouvoir déjà récolté des
moyens et ensuite de
de pouvoir financer des projets donc le
problème que nous avons actuellement au
niveau du comité c'est la difficulté de
trouver les moyens pour mettre en oeuvre
un certain nombre
deux projets alors je fais ça ne sera
pas qu'une institution académique 1 pas
du tout mais le comité n'est pas le
comité actuel qui pilote cette question
depuis 2004 n'est pas une institution
académique densément vous avez à la fois
des universitaires vous savez aussi des
représentants du monde associatif des
musées alors pour le pour le cran le
conseil représentatif des associations
noires l'état par cette fondation
s'engage à mettre en place des
réparations morales et financières car
cette fondation permettra de financer
des actions mémorielle culturelle ou
sociale
est ce que vous êtes d'accord est ce que
cette fondation c'est une façon de
réparer alors que par rapport à cette
question de réparation le mot est
tellement enfin connoté non il est
tellement de deux significations
différentes qu'il est quand même
voilà si le cran estime que c'est une
manière de réparer c'est très bien pour
ma part lorsque on évoque cette question
là moi je pose toujours la question
suivante et je m'entends je raisonne en
tant qu'historien en 1849
lorsque les colons ont reçu une
indemnité
les ja victor schoelcher il était pour
qu'on indemnise les esclaves aussi en
1849 les propriétaires d'esclaves ont
reçu une indemnité
ils étaient 7000 qui a payé cette
indemnité à votre avis qui met l'état
français oui l'état et donc l'état c'est
qu'ils les contribuables donc c'est une
petite minorité
encore une fois enfin la perspective
historique que je défends c'est une
minorité de colons avec une minorité de
négociants qui ont bénéficié de liège
petit filet collectivités à adieu a été
condamné à payer
exactement et d'autre part lorsqu'on
analyse le par exemple xviiie siècle les
français sont écrasés d'impôts pour
financer des guerres guerre de sept ans
guerre d'indépendance américaine et ses
guerres sont dès hier pour préserver
l'espace coloniale et donc les intérêts
de ces négociants et de ces colons ont
qui payent l'impôt
la plupart des couches les plus modestes
de l'époque c'est-à-dire les paysans qui
va partir à la guerre comme chair à
canon ce sont les mêmes pour est ce
qu'ils mangent du sucre est ce qu'ils
boivent du café cette population-là bien
assez peu donc voyez je fais la
différence entre ceux qui bénéficient
voilà une élite prospère qui a bénéficié
de ce système là et une masse de la
population qui non seulement n'ont
profité pas mais plutôt été obligé de
financer ces guerres coloniales pourtant
cette question de la réparation elle est
présente hier cécile duflot les députés
csu dû forcer le ministre a déposé deux
propositions de loi pour reconnaître le
travail forcé comme crime contre
l'humanité elle demander réparation pour
les préjudices résultant la traite et de
l'esclavagé elle souhaite que ce texte
soit examiné
lors de la prochaine session
parlementaire c'est ben c'est sa demande
maintenant comment on l'a indiqué ce
matin la notion de crime contre
l'humanité
donc madame taubira l'a rappelé en 2001
mais elle existait déjà des 1794 le 5
février 1794 un député de la convention
avec l'un de la première abolition de la
première abolition
l'esclavagé est un crime de lèse
humanité par conséquent les
propriétaires d'esclaves non seulement
si les autorités républicaines arrive à
les attraper il faut les tuer mais il
faut auparavant les déchoir de leur
citoyenneté
c'est la peine quand même la déchéance
de la citoyenneté ça nous rappelle un
débâcle en a eu
qu'on a eu pour punir qui pour punir ce
qu'on considère enfin comme les plus
grands criminels c'est à dire que cette
notion de crime contre l'humanité a déjà
existé alors ce sera un débat bon c'est
vrai que là j'ai pas trop réfléchi à la
question parce que je viens d'apprendre
la sotech transition assez rapidement
qu'elle nous respectons connaît-il la
création d'un mémorial aux esclaves et
puis surtout le musée de l' esclavage
alors concernant le mémorial le des noms
d'esclaves ça c'est extrêmement
important car en 1848
donc les esclaves qui n'avaient que des
prénoms on leur a donné des noms de
famille
or des noms de famille m'a par exemple
mouvement m'a donné raison mais ma grand
mère on lui a donné gérant des noms
inventés par les officiers d'état civil
ce n'était absolument pas les noms des
maîtres comme aux états unis et donc
c'est important de créer cette filiation
entre les descendants d'esclaves qui se
raccroche à un ancêtre esclave qu'il y
ait une fierté de cela parce que
longtemps ça a été une honte
ma grand mère disait non faut pas parler
d' esclavage à on est des ancêtres
africains
non faut pas parler de ça si il faut
parler de ça et il faut que finalement
inversé en quelque part le stigmate ce
qui était considéré comme négatif
devienne une source de fierté c'est le
seul moyen on peut pas avoir honte de
notre passé quand on est descendant
d'esclave
comme je le suis à mon moi je suis aussi
descendante propriétaires d'esclaves
donc vous voyez aussi quels problèmes
cela peut poser pour les réparations en
ce qui me concerne je serai peut-être
obligés de payer d'un côté
pour pour l'autre donc voilà ça c'est
important de enfin voila moi la réponse
est toujours une réponse historique
merci beaucoup merci frédéric régent
d'avoir répondu en direct en question
merci
il est 19h toujours en direct sur public
sénat tout de suite le rappel des titres
et législatif continue de se coller chic
et politique à gauche le sort de manuel
valls n'en finit pas de faire des vagues
jean luc mélenchon qui rompt avec les
communistes sera candidat à marseille à
droite à la santé c'est fait mais dans
la douleur
et l'ondé de choc déclenchée par
l'élection emmanuel macron ne s'arrête
pas aux murs du palais bourbon
la seconde pourrait se faire sentir
jusqu'au sénat où un groupe
parlementaire en match pourrait voir le
jour et entraîner une recomposition
politique inédite comme on va gouverner
le nouveau président le recours aux
ordonnances pour réformer le code du
travail inquiète les partenaires sociaux
laurent berger le secrétaire général de
la cfdt l'encouragent à partager le
pouvoir
quand françois hollande fait l'éloge du
dialogue social on en parle dans notre
second débat et je vous rappelle que
vous pouvez réagir sur twitter à cette
émission hashtag présidentielle 360 je
vous le disais à l'instant les adieux de
françois hollande qui a présidé ce matin
son dernier conseil des ministres
faisant l'éloge du dialogue social dans
un message implicite à emmanuel macron
julien desvages les mines sont graves et
les sourires timides autour de la table
17 ministres et 20 secrétaires d'état
tous les membres du gouvernement sans
exception sont présents
dernière prise de parole sous les
dorures du salon murat à l'issue de ce
conseil des ministres françois hollande
est applaudi par tout son gouvernement
c'est un moment à la fois solennel un
moment grave et en même temps un moment
qui n'est pas triste parce qu'on sait
que d'une certaine façon le travail
accompli et on en est fier sur le perron
de l'elysée françois hollande prend le
temps de saluer un à un chacun de ses
collaborateurs
tous ont conscience qu'une page se
tourne certains ont même voulu garder un
dernier souvenir c'est le crayon que le
président de la république est là sur sa
table ministre est parti de la demande
et si je pouvais je prendrais
mais conservera donc ses cinq salles
pour les mets pour son 250e et ultime
conseil des ministres le président de la
république a tenu à adresser un dernier
message très politique
l'acte qui a été posé dans ce
quinquennat de m le dialogue social au
coeur de la transformation de l'économie
c'est un point très important sur lequel
il a beaucoup c'est vrai insisté
et il a dit que chaque fois qu'on avait
pu que quelquefois l'oublier ça pouvait
coûter cher une mise en garde destinée à
son successeur emmanuel macron qui veut
aller vite et gouverner par ordonnances
mercredi prochain c'est lui qui
présidera ce conseil des ministres avec
sa nouvelle équipe comme smart
chroniqueuse à public sénat on voit qu
emmanuel macron veut légiférer par
ordonnance est ce que c'est un passage
en force qui inquiète notamment les
partenaires sociaux oui effectivement un
première attaque hier matin dans une
matinales radio
philippe martinez le secrétaire général
de la cgt déclare que gouverner par
ordonnances et ne pas écouter ne pas
respecter la démocratie
pas très étonnant de la part de la cgt
dont on connaît l'opposition un radical
à emmanuel macron mais c'est ensuite la
traire réformatrice cfdt qui lui emboîte
le pas laurent berger dans une lettre
ouverte publiée dans le quotidien le
monde a envoyé ces quelques phrases qui
demande à emmanuel macron de partager le
pouvoir donner de l'air à notre société
hésite encore le mythe de l'homme
providentiel est un mythe dangereux pour
notre démocratie
et puis il conclut avec cet
avertissement très clair une nouvelle
réforme du code du travail surtout ciel
est mené sans concertation ne peut pas
non plus être une recette miracle pour
cent on entendu ségolène royal ce matin
défendre son ancien collègue louis la
ministre de l'écologie sur rtl ce matin
non la méthode macron ce n'est pas le
passage en force nous dit-elle emmanuel
macron c'est qu'il ne faut pas brusquer
on écoute la ministre de l'environnement
ce que je peux vous dire on a deux des
manuels macron c'est qu'il n'a pas du
tout l'intention de brutaliser les
français comme nous tous il a été
choqué par l'ue des usages du 49-3 par
le gouvernement précédent donc ça sera
pas sa méthode ça je puis vous le dire
il justement parce qu'ils cassent les
codes traditionnels des oppositions aux
brutales entre la droite et la gauche
c'est précisément pour faire émerger des
solutions de consensus qui font en sorte
que lorsque les français adhèrent à une
solution et la comprennent
à ce moment là la croissance et
économique il nous revient vous avez
bien entendu emmanuel macron a été
choqué un par l'utilisation du 49-3 sur
son propre texte donc sur la fameuse loi
macro pour cette prochaine réforme du
droit du travail il entend procéder par
ordonnance est ce que c'est aussi un
moyen de contourner finalement le
parlement bien sûr le principe une
ordonnance permet aux pouvoirs exécutifs
de légiférer rapidement en évitant de
longs débats parlementaires on va voir
comment ça se passe il ya trois phases
pour les ordonnances d'abord le
parlement vote une loi d'habilitation
qui précise sur quel sujet et pendant
quelques périodes le gouvernement peut
prendre des ordonnances et l'a déjà
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron a besoin
d'avoir une majorité au parlement
ensuite eh bien les ordonnances sont
adoptés en conseil des ministres après
la vie qui est consultatif du consul du
conseil d'état et ensuite elles sont
signées par le président de la
république et dès lors et bien les
ordonnances sont applicables
et puis il ya une troisième phase le
moment où le parlement vote va examiner
vote le projet de loi de ratification de
l'ordonnancé
si tout va bien le texte est adopté et a
valeur de loi
et si ça ne va pas et bien le texte
reste un décret a une valeur
réglementaire mais c'était un tel revers
politique il faut bien le dire que le
texte a bien du mal à s'appliquer
mais l'exercice est encore plus délicat
quand ça concerne le gros du travail qu
effectivement parce que depuis la loi
larcher de 2007 à l'époque gérard
larcher ministre du travail bien tout
texte qui implique une modification du
code du travail que ce soit 20 de la loi
elle comme riz ou la loi rebsamen
récemment doit débuter par une phase de
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux
en clair avant de légiférer le
gouvernement doit se concerter avec
leurs syndicats et leur demander s'ils
veulent ouvrir une négociation entre eux
et là il faudrait même que cette face
avant la loi d'habilitation on dit
d'ailleurs qu'il maniait le mac on
devrait recevoir très rapidement les
partenaires sociaux à l'elysée
dès la semaine prochaine c'est en tout
cas possible mais bon faut dire aussi
que mr larcher elle est très souple la
consultation
ça peut être juste recevoir des
partenaires sociaux en bilatéral comme
ça a été fait sur la loi elle comme
répit dernière possibilité si le
gouvernement invoque l'urgence on peut
même sauté cette phase de concertation
reste que vu le contexte vu les
avertissements des syndicats des signaux
de dialogue de la part du gouvernement
serait plus que bienvenu merci beaucoup
ta main pour toutes ces précisions alors
la méthode macron va-t-elle provoquer
une crise sociale dans le pays on en
parle tout de suite avec mes invités et
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau yves veyrier bonsoir vous êtes
secrétaire confédéral de force ouvrière
merci d'être avec nous le maire il est
également sur ce plateau bonsoir vous
êtes secrétaire général de l'unsa jacky
également boris blazy pardon vous êtes
membre de la direction de confédérale de
la cgt et jean charles simon bonsoir
êtes économiste et entrepreneurs merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir accepté mon
invitation on entendu et bien philippe
martinez estimé que gouverner par
ordonnance ce n'est pas écouté la
démocratie borie ce plat dit pourtant ça
fait partie des moyens dont dispose la
constitution française c'est quand même
légale de procéder par ordonnance
oui ça serait peut-être légal mais c'est
certainement une première faute
politique que pourrait avoir pour effet
ray manuel macron considéré que le
dialogue social la négociation les
changes avec les organisations
syndicales serait quelque chose de super
fut à ses yeux aurait certainement de
graves conséquences pour une ouverture
de mandature et y compris sa rentrerez
un petit peu dans la droite ligne de ce
qu'on a déjà vécu au précédent mandat
avec l'utilisation du 49-3 plusieurs
reprises avec la loi travail ça serait
certainement le de nature encore une
fois aggraver la rupture entre l'élite
politique et puis le monde du travail en
particulier les salariés qu'est ce que
vous lui dites vous le mettez en garde
contre un troisième tour social emmanuel
macron bay on le met en garde contre le
fait de vouloir légiférer en urgence de
cette manière là dans le but parce que
le but il est là dans le but
de favoriser des régressions sociales
pour les salariés en vue de faire
profiter les exigences du patronat et en
particulier le medef et le cac40 donc
effectivement la cgt cela d'helmand en
demande à emmanuel macron deux sortes ou
pas utiliser ce type de méthodes d'une
part sur le fond sur la forme et sur le
fond surtout pas de régression sociale
on a vu ce que ça a pu donner ces
dernières ces derniers jours en termes
de résultats politiques et notamment
avec une montée du front national dans
le pays qui inquiète tout le monde lui
vers l est ce que vous êtes prêts à
soutenir emmanuel macron dans sa
démarche de réformer le code du travail
par relance non je pense que mon
collègue de la cgt l'a dit j'ai pas
exactement la même appréciation mais on
pourrait commencer par appliquer tout
simplement la loi qui s'appelle la loi
larcher c'est l'article l 1 du code du
travail
réformer le code du travail ça peut
commencer par l'appliquer c'est à dire
considéré qu' il les partenaires sociaux
doivent être consultés avant qu'on
légifère
c'est tout simplement le la
préconisation recevoir les partenaires
sociaux et avoir une première prise de
contact pour un président de la
république qui s'installe c'est une fort
bonne idée maintenant c'est pas
l'application de la loi larcher la loi
larcher précise qu'on reçoit pas
simplement pour une visite de courtoisie
on doit discuter effectivement d'une
réforme éventuelle de son contenu et
c'est tout le problème d'ailleurs dans
cette façon de procéder par ordonnance
est pas une atteinte à la démocratie
vont pas tomber en dictature on est dans
un cadre qui reste constitutionnel
simplement il ya un cadre qui permet ou
non plus ou moins le dialogue social est
celui-là fermerait les choses et
contribuerez attendre une situation
qu'il est déjà suffisamment quand on
voit l'état de division politique existe
en france qu'est la position de force
ouvrière aux ordonnances mais à écouter
tout d'abord le
le président de la république qui doit
être investi dimanche laissent entendre
qu'il veut redonner du crédit à la
parole politique
c'est sans doute nécessaire et urgent
mais il ya un premier problème il avait
dit lui même qu'il ne croyait pas une
seconde à la réforme par ordonnance en
novembre dernier le la seconde n'a pas
duré très longtemps donc évidemment les
ordonnances font partie de l'arsenal
constitutionnel il ya des bons et des
mauvais exemples le bon exemple c'est
l'ordonance de 1982 qui a institué les
39 heures la réduction du temps de
travail à 39 heures est la cinquième
semaine de congés payés
mais cette ordonnance moi je les ici
sous les yeux ce qu'elle disait c'est
que la présente ordonnance a notamment
respecter l'équilibré instituée par les
partenaires sociaux dans le protocole
d'accord du 17 juillet 80 donc il y
avait eu au préalable non seulement une
concertation mais une négociation qui
avait débouché sur un accord sur lequel
s'était appuyé le président de l'époque
françois mitterrand pour prendre cette
ordonnance
il ya un très mauvais exemple celle
ordonnance de 2005 qui a institué le cn
eux sans concertation aucune et entre le
cnl cpe on voit comment ça c'est donc
face aux parlementaires pour quand même
débattre de ces projets thème traduit
l'évoqué est bien d'habilitation pour
habiliter dans le gouvernement à
légiférer par ordonnance
écoutez justement l'absolu un débat
parlementaire même s'il est plus cool
pour habiliter le gouvernement à agir
par ordonnance mais fo ne veut pas faire
les choses à l'envers on pense nous
d'abord la concertation et on verra
ensuite le résultat la concerts déjà en
terme de contenu éventuellement de
méthode mais c'est pas nous à faire mais
ça nous paraît un peu curieux que le
président on est dans une période de
maintenant d'élections législatives
on annonce que le président veut
légiférer à la place des candidats à
l'élection parlementaire donc c'est un
peu curieux donc la concertation on
verra le contenu et il sera toujours
temps de s'accorder éventuellement sur
le meilleur moyen en respectant les
différentes formes de démocratie
parlementaire et sociale
simplement on a entendu
les syndicats présents sur ce plateau la
tâche s'annonce quand même difficile
pour emmanuel macron sur ces recours aux
ordonnances
il était clair il a dit dans son
programme donc c'est une différence pour
moi un majeur par rapport à la loi et
conneries il a annoncé ce qu'il voulait
faire il annoncé la méthode
donc je vois pas du tout la même
contexte politique entre ce qu'il veut
faire et ce qui a été fait dans le cadre
du mandat précédent
par ailleurs les ordonnances comme le
49-3 ont pas lire temps en temps ça nous
plaise en temps ça nous plaît pas c'est
dont les houthis a aussi encadré par le
parlement le 49-3 également et donc le
parlement à la moyen de s'opposer
moi je trouve ça moins pour moi la soul
est l'anomalie c'est l'existence même de
la loi larcher
on est quand même des rares démocraties
où pouvoir politique n'a pas pleinement
la main sur ce qui est fondamental à
faire ou pas en matière sociale à ma
disposition l'union européenne alors le
le cas d'avoir chez ne l'est pas et il
pouvait tout à fait ne pas y être
en 2007 en france la france était un
pion par aux kurdes des dispositions
l'union européenne en 2007
la plupart de nos deux grands exemples
de réformes sociales au halal à côté de
nous en prison on regarde les warfalla
gerhard schröder elles se sont faites
sont les partenaires sociaux et même en
leur marchant dessus sans état d'âme et
c'est comme ça que l'allemagne s'est
réformée en france objectivement les
partenaires sociaux pas très
représentatif
on le voit à chaque scrutin côté
syndical comme côté patronal et en plus
ce qu'ils réforment jamais et qui savent
à peine gérer convenablement les
systèmes paritaire dont ils ont la
responsabilité
donc il me semble tout à fait légitime
et même indispensable que l'exécutif
prenne la main alors peut-être votre
réponse mais enfin les les syndicats
sont représentatifs moi je je je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de responsables
politiques qui aimeraient pouvoir être
élu de la même manière que le font les
syndicats dans les entreprises donc s'en
fait rêver plus d'un donc celle là n'est
pas la question au niveau national ça
n'a rien à voir avec ça les plus beaux
du côté syndical et de russie ont créé
les conditions pour qu'ils aient des
élections professionnelles qui 0,2 dans
de bonnes conditions de partout qu'on
laisse l'accès aux syndicats à
s'implanter dans les entreprises vous
allez voir que les salariés donneront
leur avis c'est ce qui fait qu'ils ont
l'occasion ils sont du parcours il ya
des syndicats ils le font très très bien
et donc ils sont très attachés à leur
système 5 la voix l'élection de du pe 7%
de participation dans le chai et être
moi et c'est d'accord c'est caricatural
de diarra mais je pense que là c'est pas
le propos
organiser le débat avec les syndicats
c'est uniquement pour faciliter la
discussion d'une part et crée les
conditions que les syndicats puissent
évoquer des propositions donner des
propositions et on en à à la cgt on a un
certain nombre de propositions par
exemple dans les derniers mois qui ont
précédé l'élection de d'emmanuel macron
on a rédigé et pas simplement la cgt
seule en a rédigé avec des
universitaires un projet de code du
travail du 21ème siècle qui pourrait
justement correspondre à la fois aux
défis technologiques auxquels on est
confrontés ses intentions nous on ne
sait pas qu'on est prêt à évoluer ça
fait des mois et des mois
avec ce gouvernement précédent qu'on
demande à pouvoir être reçus discuter
des propositions qui sans cesse de la
cgt et de ce côté là jusqu'à présent
d'un reçu une fin de non recevoir
et il semblerait que emmanuel macron à
ya aussi dans ce même sens donc non dits
attention attention à libérer l'on sait
que françois hollande 1 ce matin lors de
son dernier conseil des ministres a
souligné cette importance du dialogue
social oubliez pourrait coûter cher à 20
selon des propos rapportés par stéphane
le foll le porte parole du gouvernement
à la fin de son quinquennat finalement
quel regard vous portez sur le dialogue
social n'a peut-être pas été si mauvais
que ça sous françois hollande qu'est ce
que vous diriez non c'est plutôt à
marquer d'une pierre blanche parce que
on a eu à part l'épisode de la loi elle
comme rio justement n'a pas respecté les
exigences du dialogue sociale sirs que
la concertation elle a eu lieu mais une
fois que on a été contraint de lui dire
qu'elle n'avait pas été respectée donc
ça a été marquée d'un péché originel
effectivement et puis je voudrais quand
même rectifié parce que on peut être
anti syndicale c'est un peu anciens mais
enfin on a le droit de l'être ne va pas
leur dire n'importe quoi non plus on
sort très exactement de là près de la
mesure de la représentativité des
organisations syndicales
sa date de fin mars donc que je vous y
emmène moi je le connais c'est parfait
on n'irait pas parce que si vous la
connaissiez très bien vous
bêtise non non non mais vous savez on
peut être syndicaliste est pas
systématiquement imbéciles le taux de
participation dans les entreprises est
de l'ordre de 60% aux élections aux
institutions représentatives des
personnels là où il y en a voilà donc on
n'est pas dans une situation où cette
question la représentativité syndicale
serait catastrophique en france pas du
tout et d'ailleurs on vient d'avancer
pour mesurer la représentativité
patronale également puis par ailleurs ça
pose un autre sujet 13 millions 6 et
moins de 40% par ici elle veut et encore
4 millions de personnes qui ne sont pas
inscrits et qui eux pour lesquels les
payes devient pas eu de pv mesurables et
et si on veut voter moins ce qu'assure
contre la réorganisation l'audience même
de l'organisation près les salariés des
tpe 7% participation 10% et redit si on
veut comparer avec la situation
européenne justement la france est
extrêmement retard du point du dialogue
social et dans beaucoup de pays
européens on considère que la démocratie
sociale est un complément indispensable
démocratie politique et en aimant
énormément de questions ne se règle pas
d'ailleurs par la voie législative mais
par la voie de la négociation du contrat
n'est pas un pays fier autant des liens
partenaires sociaux en matière de
définition de la norme en roulant les
négociations interprofessionnelles
nationale et en matière surtout
d'ampleur du paritarisme
on est sans équivalent 135 milliards
d'euros de budget géré en direct par les
patronats et syndicats
alors qu'encore une fois je vais parler
de syndicats faut pas croire que je me
dis que les syndicats de salariés que je
visais là dedans parce que c'est
exactement pareil côté syndicat
d'entreprise 12 % de participation au
scrutin des chambres de commerce et de
l'artisanat donc si vous laissez
d'organisation elles ont peu d'adhérents
peu d'adhérents huit et demi pour cent
du privé esaïe du privé sont adhérents
d'une organisation syndicale
pourtant là les systèmes dont on parle
notamment l'assurance chômage qu'évoque
emmanuel macron c'est bien les salariés
du secteur privé qui sont les seuls
concernés
aujourd'hui et côté patronal on l'a vu à
mesure d'apprendre activité même pas
quatre cent mille entreprises au total
adhérente à une des trois organisations
et en plus souvent sans même le savoir
c'est à dire un syndicat professionnel
qui lui-même adhère à une confédération
donc en fait ces organisations - non
action pas la légitimité pour discuter
de ce qui est encore une fois s'agissant
des grands droit à des grandes
orientations se fait ailleurs par le
pouvoir politique
écoutez moi
si on entre dans les calculs de
représentativité on risque d'entrer dans
un débat il vient d'avoir lieu
d'ailleurs sur les conditions de
l'élection du président de la république
donc je pense que c'est un peu ridicule
et à l'arrivée je ne sais pas qui serait
représentative
parce qu'ils pensent savoir mieux que
les autres la filière une question pour
vous puisque on voit quand même une
recomposition politique est en train de
s'opérer dans le pays qui va au delà des
clivages partisans on voit que aussi
bien à droite comme à gauche on est prêt
à soutenir à rentrer dans une majorité
présidentielle pour éviter les blocages
qu'on a pu connaître sous le précédent
quinquennat est ce qu'aujourd'hui
laissant dickens vous représentez ne
sont pas dans cet état d'esprit est
également mais on n'est pas dans un état
d'esprit de blocage je crois que ce qui
est de 10 autour de la table est clair
on est dans un état d'esprit d'ouvrir
une négociation une concertation sur le
fond parce que si on prend la question
de la loi travail et du contenu de
l'ordonnancé éventuels ou quel que soit
le véhicule
la question par exemple du niveau de la
négociation monsieur macro on veut aller
vite pourquoi parce qu'il a la
conviction qu en décentralisant la
négociation il va favoriser l'adaptation
la compétitivité la création d'emplois
bon et bien on n'a pas la conviction que
cela fonctionnera ainsi on a plutôt le
sentiment que de renvoyer
systématiquement la négociation au plus
bas en faire l'instrument la
compétitivité c'est risqué d'entrer dans
une spirale de compétition de
concurrence entre les entreprises d'une
même branche y compris sur le territoire
national qui va mettre en compétition
les salaires le temps de travail etc
c'est exactement ce dont souffre l'union
européenne manque d'harmonisation
sociale c'est exactement ce dont souffre
la mondialisation dont on parle tant
parce que les entreprises peuvent et on
se souvient du drame durana plaza 1500
salariés qui sont morts parce que les
conditions de sécurité n'est pas
respectée qui travaillait là bas des
grandes marques qui rapportait parce
qu'elle produisait là-bas à moindres
coûts y compris au détriment de la
sécurité
donc on pense qu'il faut trouver la
bonne articulation entre les niveaux de
la négociation c'est ce qu'on appelle le
principe de faveur la hiérarchie des
normes et ya matière à discussion
là-dessus d'eau voilà où il a une
conviction on n'a pas la même conviction
on pense qu'il ya un risque de
destruction d'emplois y compris par le
biais de cette compétition
tromper on voit bien qu est ce qui s'est
passé à smart on fait un référendum aux
salariés en les menaçant de perdre leur
emploi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à wall paul il
reste quoi négocier les conditions de
licenciement
donc ça ne fonctionne pas ainsi
donc quoi il a une conviction c'est son
droit il peut argumenter à 112 des
arguments on a nos propres analyses
on peut argumenter et c'est ce qu'on
demande correspondance vont fille
travaille à plusieurs reprises on a
tenté de proposer au gouvernement en
place de sortir de ce conflit
en reprenant la négociation ce qu'on
nous a refusé
vous verriez à bruce m'a dit ok il
verrier évoqué le cas de demandes des
salariés devant le pulse on a pu voir
ces images des manuels macro justement
aller au contact des ouvriers est ce que
ça vous paraît un homme ouvert au
dialogue a les coudées salariés on sait
qu'il connaît très bien tous ces
dossiers économiques notamment pour le
cas de huit poules ça fait des mois
c'est l'industrie de la métallurgie ce
qu'on a un petit peu je suis du secteur
ça fait des mois que les salariés tirent
la sonnette d'alarmé demande à
rencontrer les responsables politiques
demandent à ce qu'on les ailes sur leurs
dossiers pointe du doigt que le groupe
américain qui génère des milliards de
profits va délocaliser leurs activités
en pologne pour pouvoir payer payer des
salariés moins cher avec un temps de
travail beaucoup plus allongée qu'en
france avec moi de protection sociale en
vue encore une fois de dégager toujours
plus de profits et ça fait des mois que
les salariés demandent à pouvoir -
discussions avec des responsables
politiques
monsieur macron il arrive au deuxième
tour des élections présidentielles c'est
un peu tard c'est un peu tard
donc moi je ne suis pas persuadé le
dossier là c'est dans les mêmes qu'on a
fait voir l écoute
est ce que c'est un homme avec qui le
dialogue social le dialogue et la
concertation avec les syndicats m facile
est possible alors pour l'instant elle
n'a pas donné le des signes de faciliter
au dialogue social quand on est à peine
investi d'une responsabilité telle que
la sienne et que la première chose qu'on
dise et je vais légiférer par
ordonnances parce que je veux me passer
de la discussion avec les organisations
syndicales et peut-être même avec le
parlement c'est pas un signe
je pense c'est pas un signe de vouloir
discuter calmement tranquillement et en
tout cas faire prendre en considération
les propositions des organisations
syndicales qui encore une fois ne
manquez pas c'est pas comme si on
découvrait le dialogue social est comme
si on découvrait
la négociation collective la négociation
collective pour les syndicats c'est tous
les jours dans les entreprises dans les
branches ont fait un tas de propositions
donc on sait faire luc bérille qu'est ce
qui ferait que j'ai quel geste de la
part des manuels auquel mâcon pour un
petit peu adoucir la position des
syndicats
non mais je crois que ça vous demander
carrément qui est retourné par
ordonnance
c'est ça le problème je pense qu'il faut
pas que la forme cash le fond si on veut
retoucher le code du travail il faut
dire sur quoi il faut qu'on puisse en
discuter
j'ai une expérience - d'emmanuel macron
la fameuse loi macron je l'avais
rencontré à l'époque
donc c'est un homme effectivement qui
peut être ouvert au dialogue
j'ai eu plusieurs plusieurs heures de
discussion avec lui sur la loi
simplement l'essentiel les discussions
qu'on a pu mener
ça s'est passé dans le cadre justement
des contacts avec les parlementaires
parce que sur l'élaboration elle même de
la loi il n'a pas été possible de se
faire entendre et c'est là-dessus sans
doute il faut ajuster les choses il faut
qu'on comprenne que il y à des
dispositions qui relèvent et on conteste
pas la démocratie politique et que le
gouvernement travaille bien évidemment
ne conteste pas simplement à un moment
donné c'est le sens de la concertation
prendre en compte l'avis des parties
prenantes celles et ceux pour lesquels
est quand même fait la loi
peut-être quand même le rappeler on
gagne effectivement qualité de la loi et
il faut donc on trouve tout simplement
la bonne articulation qui lie à je
termine juste en faisant remarquer que
dans l'état dans lequel se trouve la
france aujourd'hui et de ce que nous dit
l'élection présidentielle une france
extrêmement divisée et il ya fort à
parier pour que les lis mes
responsabilités syndicales
responsabilité de tout le monde
donc est ce que on considère que dans ce
cadre là puisque son projet c'est
justement de calmer un peu le jeu de
réconcilier les gens je pense qu'on est
réconcilie quand on les associe à
l'élaboration des politiques à la mise
en oeuvre des politiques ça s'appelle le
dialogue social
ça sera le mois de la fin avec vous est
ce que vous pensez bien qu emmanuel
macron va devoir renoncer à procéder par
ordonnance est ce que l'opposition
syndicale peut être social dans la rue
ce sera trop importante
ça dépendra d'abord de résultats des
législatives parce que pourrait
effectivement avoir cette loi
d'habilitation il faudra il faudrait
encore qu'il ait une majorité pour ça au
parlement
moi je pense qu'ensuite la question
c'est est ce qu'on veut réformer ou pas
réformer ce qu'on considère que la
situation en matière de marché du
travail de situation d'emploi en france
allez satisfaisante ou pas satisfaisante
si on considère qu'elle est pas
satisfaisante il faut faire avancer les
choses il me semble qu'effectivement il
faut que la démocratie politique à mon
prenne ses responsabilités samba dia
écartés ne pas discuter avec un bien
introduit les parties prenantes
ça veut dire que vraiment c'est à eux
d'agir encore une fois je vis dans les
pays étrangers où il ya eu des grandes
réformes qui ont été menées ces
dernières années elles ont été faites je
pense encore à matteo renzi sur le son
ou jones acte qui exactement notre sujet
de marché de l'emploi à la française
aussi il a fait au parlement tout seul
et cette réforme allait tour en a les
dents dès aujourd'hui elle a un petit
peu changé la situation en italie
c'est donc le bon chemin le pense eh
bien merci jean charles simon merci à
maurice simple a dit merci à lui que
merrill et merci à vous y verriez c'est
la fin de cette édition merci à vous
d'avoir suivi avant 2h vous retrouvez
sonia mabrouk et ses invités bonne
soirée et à demain 18h
[Musique]